el que está vendiendo boletos de una
rifa para recaudar dinero para su
escuela cada boleto cuesta 30 pesos y él
sabe que la cantidad que recauda va a
ser una función del número de boletos
que vendan cuál es el dominio y el rango
para esta función
bueno sería padre empezar con determinar
la función verdad entonces vamos a poner
la cantidad de dinero recaudado le voy a
poner ve en función del número de
boletos esto es sencillo cada boleto
cuesta 30 pesos así que si vendemos de
boletos vamos a recaudar 30 por b pesos
y lo que nos piden es determinar el
dominio y el dominio y el rango para esa
función y bueno suenan a palabras un
poco difíciles y sofisticadas pero basta
acordarse de la idea detrás para ver qué
es algo muy sencillo el dominio es
básicamente el conjunto de valores que
podemos meter en la función le voy a
poner aquí le voy a poner lo que
podemos
meter
meter en la función en la función
función y el rango es todos aquellos
valores que podemos obtener evaluando la
función en los elementos de su dominio
ahorita pasamos al rango pero bueno
vamos con el dominio cuál sería el
dominio de esta función pues saber o sea
realmente uno podría decir pues
cualquier número lo puedo multiplicar
por 20 pero hay que tener cuidado porque
esta función viene de un contexto
específico aquí eric está vendiendo
boletos entonces definitivamente pues no
va a vender no sé tres cuartos de boleto
eso sería algo muy raro y tampoco va a
vender boletos negativos eso sería como
que los comprará pero eso no nos
interesa ahorita únicamente nos interesa
que venda pues podría vender cero
boletos un boleto dos boletos a lo mejor
un millón de boletos claro después de un
punto se vuelve poco realista el modelo
pero vamos a pensar eso que puede vender
0 1 2 y así sucesivamente boletos es
decir vende boletos en cantidades
enteras y a partir de cero como
escribiríamos esto pues le vamos a poner
así que el dominio el dominio
niño es que ve
ve debe ser ve debe ser debe ser un
entero entero no negativo no negativo
según yo esto contempla lo que acabo de
decir le pongo no negativo en vez de
positivo porque con no negativo incluyo
al cero vale si le pongo positivo no
incluiría al cero pero justo esto
contempla las dos ideas verdad que sea
una cantidad entera y que sea a partir
de cero no puede ser un medio ni tres
cuartos ni otras cosas extrañas bueno
entonces ya tenemos el dominio ahora
pasemos al rango el rango es todos
aquellos valores que podemos alcanzar
entonces bueno conociendo el dominio
podemos saber cómo es el rango déjame
script déjame escribir aquí rango voy a
escribir rango
bueno rango está
y entonces cuáles son los valores los
posibles valores que podemos alcanzar
pues b b debe ser un entero no negativo
y aquí estamos multiplicando por 30 así
que yo digo que el rango son todos
aquellos múltiplos de 30 múltiplos
múltiplos de 30 de 30 pero que además
sean no negativos no negativos negativos
esto puede parecer obvio pero piénsalo
piénsalo con cuidado mira tenemos aquí
un entero no negativo y lo estamos
multiplicando por 30 así que vamos a
obtener la fuerza hacia fuercitas un
múltiplo de 30 no negativo por ejemplo
no podemos obtener 17 ni 32 es más
déjame escribir aquí algunos valores de
d por ejemplo desde cero desde cero es
igual a 30 por 0 o sea 0 desde 1 es
igual a 30 por 1 sea 30 desde 2 es igual
a 60 siempre obtenemos puros múltiplos
de 30 y así que no vamos a poder obtener
por ejemplo 20 pesos o 27 pesos a menos
que estemos haciendo las cuentas mal
pero eso no está no está contemplado
aquí verdad entonces son puros puros
múltiplos de 30 no negativos de esta
forma el rango es eso y eso viene de que
el dominio el dominio pide que sea un
pero no negativo